what's goody out breath the verse
welcome back to Hot Breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros I'm
your host comedian Joel buers and our
guest today started his comedy career
during a college trip to South Africa
shortly after moves to San Francisco
climbs up through the ranks there where
he gets to open up for comedians like
Andrew Schultz who he has since gone on
the road with he has since written for
on Schultz's Netflix show Schultz Saves
America and following the Schultz model
Our Guest today has started to create
his own opport unities on social media
going viral posting crowdwork Clips
sketches and a lot more we'll get into
today because you'll learn there's not
that much out there about them yet
because we like to catch that next wave
of Comedy stars coming up in the game
and this guy is definitely one of them
so please welcome hot Brethren and sist
to the hot breathe the one and only Joey
the hammer Avery wow thank you Hammer a
you did your homework that's crazy I
studyed up for you man people are
usually like damn so how did you start
and then I have to say all that well I I
want this to be like inside the actor
studio for comedians so inside the
comedians shitty studio apartment this
is pretty lit now we're down this is
this is sick but I mean most most
comedians but I don't live here yeah
you're like I'll be sleeping here later
100% wait you're in the middle of your
first like National headlining tour
right yeah so how's it how's it been
going man it's been great I mean it's
definitely you know it's City to City
when it's your first tour you kind of
learn you could you could be the man in
some markets and a who the [__] is that
and other if I can swear I don't let rip
uh yeah so so some markets you realize I
I guess I don't have fans here uh and
and other markets it's great but it has
just been cool to get to do that much
standup you know like actually getting
to do I had one stretch where I probably
did like 24 hours of comedy in like 22
days you know when it was I've never
experienced that before so definitely
levels you up yeah and what are some of
those rough ones you had mentioned like
how's it what's kind of been the highs
and lows of this because what you're
doing right now is basically what every
comedian is aspiring to do right now
blow up on social media go on a tour
start selling tickets but what is like
the reality of that dream the the
reality is I think with everything I
mean comedy's like anything else it's
like you have an idea of what you want
to happen and then the second you get
there you have a brand new challenge
that you're stressed about so like I try
to remind myself cuz you know when I get
the like emails from my agent that's
like ticket counts I'm like oh [__] all
right we got it we got work to do um but
I also remind myself like this is
actually was the dream for the first
decade of doing this was just to have a
chance to go on the road and headline
and and figure it out so you have to
figure out I mean the reality of it is
you have to do a lot of stuff you didn't
think you were going to do when you're a
comic it is uh
editing Clips so that those get exposure
people can see what city you're in or
I'm you know like doing data management
for email lists and you know [__] so
yeah it sucks what do you mean data
management like like uh you know
basically making sure that I mean to I
don't want to be too boring about it but
uh I've had some issues with like geoca
when I send out my emails to people who
filled out my email submission form and
so I'm figuring out all these ways to
like gather zip codes and all this [__]
that's just really boring yeah the
administrative side of this where like I
thought I would just write jokes perform
and then be famous right now you're an
email marketer and a Photoshop uh
graphic designer and a thousand other
things but the beauty of it is it's like
up to you now which is great do you do
everything
still for the most part yes but now
sometimes I can hire out help so like
sometimes I have someone shoot my shows
and edit the clips but I'm still very
involved in that process other times I'm
the one who sets up all the cameras
shoots my stuff edits the angles you
know posts it all makes the cover art
and all that [__] dude yeah you know
what's crazy is like I just interviewed
Ian bag on here and he's been doing over
30 years he's like known as like the
crowdwork guy yeah during the pandemic
he hit rock bottom got a lot of dark
thoughts at one time he actually he
talked about how he thought about
killing himself so like his wife could
get the insurance money like that's
where he was at in his career godamn and
at that moment he like he just fired his
whole team hired an editor and then he
blew up now he's going viral selling out
what was his whole team he like managers
agents like all of like the
infrastructure of comedian things they
he replaced them with like a 21y old
editor editor yeah and then just boom I
could see at some point in time like the
representation being like a Swiss army
knife like a manager who also is great
at editing and like that would be great
the hope is you want to get to a point
where you're like it is funny now Comics
like to be a successful comic you have
to basically run a small business yeah
you know um which is good and bad like I
don't hate that because again it means
it's up to you and it's not just like
you're at the whim of Hollywood and
whether you're hot or not but uh you do
have to be like yeah it's not just going
on stage and telling jokes anymore but
it's also a comic 3 months in who was
like oh I got to figure out how to go
viral before they even figure out like a
punchline yeah you know so there was
that aspect of it too I yeah I remember
I went viral like pretty early on I was
like a couple years in and I had
something pop on like the standup
subreddit I was like oh I'm going to be
this [__] and I started posting all this
[__] and like nothing else worked I was
okay for sure that was one that was one
that's all
right what what are you seeing that is
working cuz we're all kind of blindly
just basically like playing the lottery
every time we post are you starting to
see like consistent themes or topics or
is production quality a big deal what's
kind of the formula there I think for I
mean it's all relatively simple like in
the sense of like whatever gets people
to watch is what all the algorithms are
geared towards as like people watching
and staying on the platform so your best
chance is something that looks good and
sounds good so that people don't just
immediately go g and not give it a
chance but I have tried to like think
about all the angles this is a Hot Topic
this is not and what's like working and
all that and like I really do think that
in general it's like the stuff that's
the funniest that's the quickest that
makes people feel something is what's
going to work oh makes them feel
something yeah oh yeah I mean if it
inspires debate if people can if people
start I used to get upset when people
were fighting in the comments because I
was like this is not what I'm trying to
do I don't want to upset anyone and now
people get mad in the comments and I'm
like that's watch time yeah that's all
agement let it let it rip you know uhuh
so contributing to division and the
downfall of society I think is now our
our purpose that's all it's no longer
bringing people together to laugh it's
like how can we divide them with crowd
work yeah you mentioned Schultz earlier
he said something to me that I
remembered he was like cuz I used to
make these sports betting videos that I
thought were funny and like my friends
would text me like the most they liked
them the best but they never did well
and he was just like he's like yeah the
stuff that goes viral is
not he's like Comics are very
self-centered we want to think like oh
look at me this is me doing something
cool aren't people going to like that
he's like the stuff that goes that's
sharable is stuff that makes people feel
like it's about them they'll send
something to their friends oh this is so
relatable this is so us or at some
political point that they kind of feel
but they didn't know how to articulate
it so they'll be like actually this is
what I think about this I'm going to
send this to people around the office
and I thought that was an interesting
way to think about it is like oh is this
going to make people feel any anything
CU if so they'll share it yeah that's
what I've heard him say is like he would
talk about certain demographics in the
audience because then that demographic
would share it with other demographics
that they know yeah he'd be going like
viral in like Somalia you know like all
right well better not piss them off you
know [__] Pirates over there dude
yeah well you've probably seen him from
the jump thing cuz you like opened for
him like way back in the day at comedy
clubs yeah yeah I met him in uh yeah in
Sunnyville there's a club called rooster
tea feathers and like at the time he was
like you know half selling out this club
that's next to a tire store you know uh
and it's fun room you know shout out to
them but but I've got to see that to you
know I think he's gonna he's teasing
that he's going to be doing Madison
Square Garden so yeah it's been it's
been fun to watch yeah yeah and you guys
keep in touch like you guys are yeah
yeah what what other advice has he like
giving you what have you learned from
being that close to the Sun essentially
um yeah I mean it's cool to you know
he's he's really helpful with with his
advice and he anyone would say this he
takes a a time out to give a lot of
people career advice and just really
share and like try to be a good person
and try to be helpful which is so cool
and and something that I think you want
to pass on as you get a little bit of
success but I think some of the coolest
stuff is just he obviously his advice
but just watching the the team that he's
built and seeing how he's built that and
you know he's like everyone there is a
expert in their own thing and he'll hire
anybody he just hired this kid chiy
who's like a he's like 18 I don't know
he made 19 super young kid but he was
like a really talented YouTube editor
and so he had was just like great yeah
if you want to join the team like can
make it happen which is it's cool he
just moved Shifty like just moved up to
New York like Schultz was like all right
you got the job and shiy like graduated
and then just moved like no money it's
kind of to your point it's like hyper
special I like he is really really good
at a certain style of editing great
we'll get that we don't need I don't
know you know like that you need very
people who are good at stuff that you
can't do yourself like when I'm looking
at editing I can do a lot of it myself
so when I hire someone it's usually
either I'm having bandwidth issues or
it's like I have a really specific idea
for something cool I can't do that I
need to get an editor who's really good
do you edit your like City skits when
you're running for mayor you edit all
that uh some times I have edited some of
those myself but a lot of times I'll
send those to my buddy Timmy Timmy
durgen uh who's who's great and he he
adds like he adds stuff that I can and
always whenever I get the edit back from
him I'm like oh that's so much better
yeah so much better um yeah I met him
working at uh Chubby's clothing brand
and he was like doing a bunch of their
edits and uh and he helps me out stuff
yeah do you still work for them uh I
have been part-time for for the last few
months so it's like I used to be very
heavily involved and I was part-time and
I was kind of just helping with copy and
like helping supplement like The Upfront
cost of going on tour with some needs
that they still had and I think as of
next week the end of next week I'll
officially have no more day job oh snap
which is great except for the fact that
my tour is also winding down
so we looking for new ways to make money
I'll be on the poll here Magic
City
yeah we got to have multiple streams man
you know theun overleveraged 100% yeah I
learned that during the pandemic of like
overnight I'm unemployed as a comedian I
was like oh what else is there yeah are
you
full-time how long have you been I've
been doing stay up 13 years and I
probably went full-time eight or nine
years in I think it yeah I know I knew a
lot of guys like in the open mic days
and they were like you got to be all
bought in you can't have a backup plan
and I was like yeah but but now I can
buy a camera you
know like I don't want to nobody was at
the coffee shop writing jokes 10 hours a
day while I was doing other [__] and I
probably rote more than people because I
would write on the way to work and on
the way to the mic and then it's you
know it's like if you have a little bit
less time you're probably going to get
more done if you're in swing there's
accountability yeah it's like I that's
something I definitely would like tell
younger Comics is like yeah you may want
to jump in and be fulltime it's like a
lot of fulltime Comics I know live in
their car yeah like you know like it's
not great and you want comedy to still
be fun and if it's if it's it's your
like your means of living it can suck
the fun out really quick and it just
it's not I mean you're going to develop
at the rate you're going to develop but
for a lot of people it's just going to
take a long time and so you actually buy
yourself extra years by taking some
pressure off which does help you
creatively get to where you want to be
instead of just having to you know rough
it in your car well especially like a
comedy adjacent job like you did with
like Chubbies didn't you just like email
them and then like you just start
working with them yeah I went to uh I
was in I was in sales at the time and a
comedian you know Dave Nill yes he he's
doing really well he's crushing now he
ran this conference called funny Biz and
he was like I know you hate your sales
job you should come to this marketing
thing I have tons of funny marketing
people and maybe you'll meet someone you
like and there was a dude Mason from
chubby spoke at that and was basically
like yeah we live in San Francisco and
we just make viral videos for a living I
was like are you [__] me like that's
what I want to do so I went home that
night immediately and like sent an email
with like all my like clips and like
stuff that I'd done and then yeah got
the job and for five years was able to
we had like a comedy podcast at the the
peak of it for what I was having fun we
had like a we were just an hourlong
comedy podcast we're doing skits and
like that was it that was my job was
awesome uh um and then it did help me
learn how to it helped me learn how to
edit uh it helped me learn how to use
Photoshop it helped me learn how to do
email marketing so all the stuff that I
do now for myself a lot of those skill
sets were learned from from doing it
there yeah that's what I've I've even
done like I've written for like Harmon
Brothers they create like viral um like
advertisements for companies so I've
like written some for them as well so I
think there's different ways you can
Beyond just standing on a stage you can
get created with how you make money in
this game Beyond on stage totally it's
getting harder for Brands to go viral
now cuz I there was a time where it was
like oh we have a following we'll just
make funny [__] and now it's like social
media is so competitive now they're
competing with like all the Comedians
and all the musicians everyone's just
putting [__] out there that's I'm almost
at a point now dude it's like so many
comedians are doing this like doing this
one thing that I'm almost like I'd
rather this show blow up and then like I
just keep developing as a comedian
instead of like you're saying the grind
is literally like perform record it edit
it like like basically optimize it to be
sharable and like there's so many
different things Beyond just being funny
on stage where I'm almost like I I may
just keep just doing the show and hope
that this works and just keep developing
as a comedian and doing colleges and
stuff like totally I mean yeah I think
attacking it on multiple fronts is
always the best way to go because you
have no idea what's going to stick like
I'm like doing well in the clip game now
but I'm like okay I need to start a
podcast because I need even if it's a
smaller Community a more dedicated
Community that'll be like listening
every week and like you know and also
it's fun I think at the end of the day
you do have to listen to yourself a
little bit and be like what do I want to
do yeah what what is exciting to me yeah
do you want to live on the road May once
you start getting out on the because
pre- pandemic I was getting on the road
a lot and I got home during the pandemic
and I was like I don't know if I want to
just live or rely on the road it is
funny sometimes you're like can we do a
balance like I had like a crazy tour and
it was awesome I wanted to do it I mean
it was it was great and uh they did a
great job setting it up but um yeah
there was a moment where I was like we
could save some of these markets and do
like a couple every month I can focus on
them and do like content about that
market and try and like you know build
up towards that instead of just emptying
the clip on everything all at once um so
there's a thousand ways to do it I think
that the the real thing is no one can
decide for you you just got to figure
out what you want do CU it's like yeah
traveling all the time isn't great but a
rewarding headlining show and especially
if it's filmed well and you get Clips
out of it it's like that's that's the
best for me right now and and what
percentage of your show because a lot of
what you do have you do Post jokes as
well and you post hilarious sketches as
well but like what percentage of your
show is like now crowdwork and is like
that portion really literally just like
all right clip time yeah I uh I I would
say it's probably like on on average
it's probably 40% material 20% crowd
work and I would say if you ask the
average person on the way out of the
show they would tell you it was uh wait
I just didn't that didn't even
Addy that was that's amazing so here's
the reason that I the reason that I did
that 40 minutes material 20 minutes
crowd yeah I was like wait percent yeah
40 minutes of material 20 minutes crowd
work and I think the way people's brains
work when they leave the show they would
tell you it was 40 minutes crowd work 20
minutes material because they think it's
like but ultimately what I do is I have
segments where it's like I know with
this current hour I'm going to start
with this I'm going to do crowd work
about this and then it will lead to this
segment and then that way I can kind of
do the whole thing live and like plug in
segments where something happens so that
I can just go with the flow of where the
crowd work takes me but I know where the
next one's going to hit dud what is like
how do you how do you develop crowd
workor as like what are do you give me
like crowd workor tips for comedians
because everyone's trying it now yeah
that one's tough because I do think that
like I people it's so funny people
online are like it's a you plan it I'm
like you think that I write scripts and
hire actors that's what you think I do
it's so much easier to just be yourself
and that is my advice is to just be
yourself like I think that you do have
to be authentic I don't really like
using tricks like I think that the
funniest stuff comes from just like
being in the moment and and interacting
with people that works better for my
style of Comedy CU I am like personable
tough if you're like a dry oneliner
comic like but I guess I would say
everyone's going to do it their own way
I think sometimes people's lean is to be
too mean and it like turns people off
and like obviously you want to be funny
but like I feel like I get better stuff
when we all feel like we're laughing
together and then people are more
willing to share with me and the whole
audience doesn't feel like I'm being a
dick um and I don't feel like I'm being
a dick cuz I don't like I don't I got
into comedy to you know be a people
pleaser not not to be the coolest bully
so sometimes they think it could be it's
kind of like what Steve hoffstead
probably like started this crowd work
stuff way back in the day and like
comedian destroy destroyers so now maybe
comedians feel like the way to go viral
is like destroy Heckler yeah there was a
real like there definitely was an era of
Comedy that was all about it was like
the Bill Hicks level of like you [__]
mouth breathing idiots and the like Bill
Burr Philly thing there's a [__] you
Persona and that that's fine it's just
you better be about that life better be
authentic and yeah exactly and it has to
match up with the rest of your act I
can't be [__] you [__] you [__] you and
then go into material that's not that
guy so yeah you know everyone talks
about finding your voice but like really
what it is is like how authentic can you
be on stage and then everything will
come out in that voice oh I think do you
feel like you've tapped in I feel like I
have glimpses but I don't feel like I've
been like oh I found my voice yeah I
don't because of the phrasing of that I
never felt that way because it's like it
it doesn't feel that way but I do think
that I have and like ultimately I guess
I think it's a lot more like standup is
not uh you're not constructing something
I think you're not I was never trying to
build a person ality it was more
sculpting it was like getting all the
inauthentic [__] and scraping it down to
just being like kind of the funny
version of me that exists with it inside
me on stage and I do feel like that I
have found that like I feel like I'm
just very comfortable up there you know
how did you do it what did you how did
you start to sculpt it's like how' you
start to sculpt there just being on
stage and just being like I I do think
like a lot of the shitty shows that I've
done help me figure it out because I
realiz realized I can't just do this
joke right now cuz there's four people
in this bar and it's honestly
sociopathic for me to be hitting my
Beats and like so I just had to because
it would felt so awkward to me that I
had to just start talking to people and
that's that's how I developed the crowd
work skill but it's also it's helped my
writing because it's just more like it's
more natural you know is it do did you
start to write about certain things that
came off as authentic or was it you mean
like in at those shows you more were
like conversational or trying to I pull
up I remember uh San Francisco I would
do this one at a place called The SF
Eagle it was a it was not only a gay bar
it was a leather gay bar nice so there
were some dudes getting dominated back
there I think we walked out one time and
a dude was [__] a guy in the ass and
we were like whoa dude they were
definitely on Molly but there was only
like six people in like the whole place
it was insane uh it was an awesome Place
dude that you know it was it was just
San Francisco's Health bartender Steve
great dude D AIDS but he was like it's
fine now I take pills I'm good you
know Eagle baby it was an awesome place
but uh yeah it's like I'd go up there
there' be a dude like in the front row
like wearing nipple clamps and you know
I had I would have written some like
inspired thing about how like we're all
like bits of like Cosmic like dust and
like atams cuz I saw like one Neil
degross Tyson video and I wanted to like
blow people's minds on some like Carlin
[__] right cuz I always would write like
stuff that I thought was interesting and
then try to make it funny but then it's
like you launch into that and I was just
felt like a loser so then I just had to
be like up with the nipple
clamps and not the mean way you can't
piss off a nipple clam guy he might you
know tie up to a car battery I he's one
of the six people there you don't want
to walk the crowd exactly uh so yeah I
just got used to like trying to
like I just didn't want to bomb so I was
just trying to like talk to people and
and I think that with that in mind you
start you start writing on stage a
little bit and then you just start like
the stuff you start writing just comes
out in in your voice a little bit easier
but there honestly there are still times
where I'll write something and I'll look
at it before a show and I'll just go
what the [__] dude that's not going to
work and that's not you and like that's
like belongs in your diary for sure but
you
know but don't you organize all your
jokes and like a notion thing do you
still do that I do have notion I mean
the organization should be better but
like I do have all my like sets and like
show notes you know in a in a notion
dock that you like will reference do you
are you disciplined at that I always so
like what I do is like on the headlining
tour what I'll do is like I'll take I
know what the hour is but I still like
seeing it written out for every show so
I'll like copy what I have I'll paste it
over to the new uh like last night I was
in Louisville I'll copy that I'll paste
it over to Atlanta I'll write some like
local jokes up top and then I'll go back
to my notes from Louisville which either
I'll write after I get off stage or I'll
review the footage and I'll write stuff
that I said differently stuff that
worked and I'll look at like all the
like new stuff that I need to pay
attention to so that I make sure that I
hit those tags oh okay yeah and then if
I have a new idea for something I'll
plug that in too but yeah we can we can
always mantiz like I'm going to review
this I'm going to find new things but
most of the time it's like oh I hate
myself yeah yeah but it is the flip side
of that is like I get I don't like have
anxiety is a loaded word because it's an
actual term but like I'll get nervous
for shows and the way that I'll deal
with that is just by like going over my
notes like a lot and that actually does
help me is I'm just like okay I want to
hit this I want to hit that and that's
kind of how I deal with being nervous
how do you deal with the highs and lows
of this game cuz like I've been going on
a roller coaster lately dude like like
how how do you keep keep it fresh or
keep it motivated CU I mean I've gone
through like since the pandemic man
there's been moments of like I even want
to do this like yeah and I've never felt
like that but like lately I've been
thinking that and it's it is like a
relationship with comedy to where you're
like it's like sometimes it's all love
and other times you resent it but it's
like I've kind of been going through it
right now for some reason I don't know
why yeah no it can be tough I mean I
think a lot of people do and I think it
is it's probably helpful for people
especially if it's like Comics listening
to hear that you know people go through
that I've definitely had moments where
I've thought about quitting or I've left
like a show and just been like in tears
like this is but it's been a while but
ultimately I think for me when I H when
I have moments of being like Oh I'm not
where I want to be um my thought is
always like what is something new that I
can do um and like okay so stuff isn't
working okay I should write a sketch or
try a new format of video that I've
never tried before because my thought is
usually just like okay like it's not
like oh I'm not going to make this work
it's like okay what I'm doing isn't on
the path of where I want to go you know
but I'm like I have no doubt that I'm
going to get where I'm going but if I'm
in a rut I try to figure out like what I
need to do in that moment to shake
things up and try something new and
sometimes you stumble upon brand new
ground so like I do these mayor videos
promote shows and that was cuz I was
like going to it was my first uh I'll
take one of those when you uh my buddy
just got back with some Topo chica no
I'm good I'm good I'll I'll pass out
smart I'll take a nap it's a it's a
stimulant for me um I
uh um
nice yeah I uh those those came about
because of like being nervous about I
was my first first headlining show in
San Francisco and I was like I couldn't
even sleep one night cuz I was like how
am I going to sell tickets I have no
idea how to sell tickets and it just
like popped into my head and so because
I was like I want something that's local
that's about the area and then so yeah I
guess when stuff's not going well I try
to just get creative oh yeah and try new
things that's smart Okay that that's
very helpful yeah yeah yeah I think so
what do you what do you do when you're
feeling that way yeah I mean it's it's
really I mean of course I've had
terrible shows and stuff through the
years but like it's only recently where
I've been like man I don't I don't know
if I want to do this anymore so like
I've been leaning into the podcast more
like I've really been focused on making
this the best it can be and leveling up
the production as some people may be
able to tell I don't know on this one
but well you you made a house call on
this one so yeah but um yeah and I've
been leaning into this more and focusing
I I'll still do stand up but it's more
like like like I said I just came back
from a college I'm still doing like gigs
I'm not really out there grinding mics
and like trying to develop new new new
new I'm just like I'll do the job you
can also develop new in the midst of
doing good gigs you don't have to
Forever like it does there is a a level
of years in where it can probably be a
little counterproductive because you
start playing B like it's so important
for so much of Comedy to just get
comfortable on stage like we're yeah
yeah yeah I think I I do jokes that are
Staples of my you know hour that are
some of the best parts of it that I
think would probably bomit a mic oh
potentially you know it's just a
different kind of you have it's a
different environment to survive in in a
mic where there's only two people
listening yeah for sure and I but I feel
like as comedian maybe it's like we're
just so ingrained to be like well I've
got to be grinding or I'm not a comedian
but there is the value to that of like
taking higher quality shows and just
working on stuff there and like grinding
might be doing a podcast or learning how
to you know whatever you need to do with
this giant light yeah you
know grinding comes in a lot of in a lot
of areas but you do have to do it like
that is the one thing with the modern
eras it's like you
gota you you can't just be like a uh you
know we I used to have this romantic
notion of being like an artist like
floating around just thinking about [__]
and like writing in a notebook and
smoking a Sig or whatever but it's like
no we're we're grinding on Adobe
Premiere oh yeah and then it crashes
every 10 minutes like you can't find the
media it's like yeah that's all part of
it yeah you know but you know it just
kind of lines like what do you what do
you want to happen and uh are the things
you're doing giving you a chance to get
there yeah I really I really want this
to be like inside the actor studio for
comedians like I really want this to be
the show where comedians want to come on
to show that like the serious side of
comedy of like we're all funny on stage
but like we're working non-stop type
deal you know like kind of look behind
the curtain and then also for comedians
to be like oh so this is the reality of
what takes to become a comedian right so
that's yeah I mean I'm I'm cool with
that more than like becoming like an
arena act you right right if that
happens cool but I'm more focused this
like this doesn't exist like there's
comedians doing things and building an
audience and this could be me just
trying to cut a corner right but I I
feel like this doesn't exist so I'm
leaning more in on this right now no I
mean it makes sense and it's like
helpful to hear that cuz otherwise like
if this was a normal podcast I'd be like
no one gives a [__]
like all this like backend like oh I'm
editing and I'm sending emails and like
no you know let's just be funny and you
know yeah make a kooky joke about the
horrible war crimes that are going on or
you know just normal
comedy yeah there's over 400 episodes of
this so I yeah yeah yeah no it's it's a
valuable resource and I think uh yeah I
think it it's got to be I I hope that
open micers and you know people coming
up can can hear some of this cuz it's
it's going to be different than you
think yeah but uh it is a really it's a
really rewarding Journey if you do it
the right way I think well do you have
any um like I always ask guests on here
as we start to land the plate like their
worst bombing boo story is there one
that just gives you PTSD every time you
think about it yeah they're
definitely definitely two times in my
career that I definitely like legit had
like tears in my eyes going home and was
like I'm done and like one was inan
Francisco there's a there's a great bar
next to Cobbs Comedy Club called the
rockas and they would have comedy there
it's not a great room for comedy and
like I don't even remember specifically
what happened but it was just it was one
of those shows where I was like I was so
excited about my new joke I was like
this is like a new era for me as artist
like yeah it's funny but like it's
thought-provoking you know and I'm
bringing it into like an open m full of
you know drunks and uninterested
Comedians and and it just ate [__] and I
was so my expectations were so high and
I remember walking out and it was just
it was a San Francisco night it was
foggy it started raining and I swear to
God the entire walk home was uphill I
was just like [__] metaphor
dude was bad yeah yeah and another one
was just the same thing just
expectations of like this is going to be
a good joke and it just sucked and like
the other one I was living at my parents
house I didn't have a job it was right
after I got out of college and uh and I
was just like I don't know if this is
going to [__] work and you just
started and you're like I don't know man
I don't know if it's going to work like
cuz the expectations were high when I
first I remember I got off stage the
first time I did seven minutes the
second time I did an entirely new seven
and I was like all right I'm 14 minutes
in the like I'm him yeah I was like dud
I'm when I get back to when I get back
to the States I'll start shopping this
around HBO you know we're getting and
then now you know 10 years in I'm like I
could probably do a YouTube
special I'm at that level I think is
that is that what you're working towards
cuz that's all your don't tell yep but I
have yeah you hav't a put like a full
special yeah I think that I think that's
the next step it's either deciding if I
want to do another D or or sell Fun the
full special which I think I want to do
is just then you start looking at the
price of like if you want to get that
shot at a high level God Dam I think
they're doing longer specials now they
are and I got a price quote and I was
like God
damn but and it's it was it's I mean
they're great and that's probably who I
want to do it with but um you know it's
just it is a when you start looking at
that level of investment you're just
like you start looking at your own
material and you're like oh is this good
and I I don't want to get to the point
like you can talk yourself out of doing
anything cuz I could forever be like I
need to clean this up and do that and
just get in the way of yourself doing
anything
but it's also helpful to just have a
lens of like is this as good as it can
be can I make this better or am I just
trying to be like yeah this is what I'm
doing right here it is so we'll see well
do do you have any closing advice for
comedians out there yeah I think uh the
for prospective comedians who always ask
they're like I've been writing and
saying it all just do it like just just
get going that's all that matters is
just like just get going just go to
Mike's you're going to meet people early
on also be nice and be cool you're going
to meet people early on in your journey
and you have no idea those are going to
be the most important people in your
life 10 years later they could be your
best friends they could be your worst
enemies they could be people with an
opportunity whatever just like it's a
community it's a small community it
feels a lot bigger when you start
because there's a lot more people but if
you move up the funnel you're going to
be around the same people so like for
sure be cool be kind and just don't
overthink it just start working and and
shit'll happen but when you're I think
what we said like when you when you're
at your lowest just turn back to why you
did it in the first place which is being
creative and try something different
just try to be
funny well Joey Avery thanks for on hot
breath man absolutely thanks for having
me hey do you want to plug your anything
you have for the yeah absolutely so yeah
socials are all Joey Avery um so I got
Instagram Tik Tok Facebook I got a
subreddit now um Joe Joe AR Curry AR
Curry he's killing it on he's killing it
and I posted something that was going
viral on Reddit and someone was like hey
you should have your own sub like him
yeah uh and so I looked at his and I was
like holy [__] this is amazing so I
started one and then websites Joey
avery.com and I got all I'm on tour I've
got by the time this comes out in New
York uh November 11th Philly November
12th uh Boston December 10th and San
Jose uh December 20th love it awesome
thank you so much Joey absolutely thanks
for having me H breath